[Music]
the rollout of the kovit 19 vaccine
is the moment millions have been waiting
for
in the hope it will mean a return to
normality
but many factors like some of the
vaccines being difficult to store
mean there is no guarantee they will be
distributed fairly around the world
as people in rich countries such as
britain get their first shots
how can those in less developed areas
get theirs
as well
this is your covert 19 special here on
dw i'm chris colbert welcome
african countries have been faring much
better in the pandemic than
many experts had feared despite initial
doubts for example about the
impossibility of social distancing in
communities
where large families often share a
single room
but with the coronavirus vaccines roll
out developing nations could now run
into logistical
financial and cultural roadblocks
the race for a covet 19 vaccine is
almost
over three inoculation candidates
are in the final stages of approval
and for renowned south african scientist
professor shabir madhir
the road to a vaccine has been difficult
so it's only been 12 months since we
first discovered uh
the riders that causes government 19 and
in that 12 month period what we've been
able to achieve as scientists
is develop not one but three vaccines
that have now been shown to be safe as
well as
to be effective in preventing covet 19
that itself
is a phenomenal achievement in the
scientific community
included among these three vaccines are
two vaccines that are actually being
evaluated in south africa
south africa has bore the brunt of
covered 19 devastation
on the african continent at the
beginning of december
the country had officially recorded over
820
000 infections and 22 000 deaths
infections are again rising amid worries
of an
imminent second wave and south africans
taking part in vaccine trials
are determined to play their part in
fighting a pandemic
i want to take part in this trial to
prevent myself and others from getting
corona
but not all of the potential vaccines
are suitable for the developing world
and wealthy nations stand at the front
of the queue
the modern vaccine that was funded as
part of operation warp speed is unlikely
to go outside of the u.s in a
foreseeable future and that's the
conditions
of the u.s funding the vaccine the
physical vaccine which needs to be
stored at all for low temperatures
minus 70 degrees celsius unfortunately
makes it highly
unlikely for that vaccine to be deployed
in its current formulation in a country
such as south africa
so what's left behind is really the
estradiol vaccine which is a vaccine
that we're also evaluating currently in
south africa
as being the preferred candidate for
immediate deployment
in the country even if south africa can
secure
enough doses for its population of
nearly 60 million
community workers still need to convince
a skeptical public
i'm scared of the side effects and stuff
i have to know much more
because you know all of us we're not we
are sick in different ways
right we all need to you'll need to tell
us if maybe i have hiv yeah
what am i saying
advocacy workers must also compete with
the daily realities
of one of the world's most unequal
societies
it is not one of the major issues they
have to worry about
they most of the times are worried about
bread and butter issues
but professor mahdi remains resolute
that south africa will lead africa's
charge
for a safe and sustainable solution to
the global
they were doing this pandemic the data
that's being accumulated in a vaccine
trials that we're currently doing
uh will really provide uh evidence to
make an informed decision
as to which vaccines are suited for the
south african context
beyond that it's really up to government
to manage the process to ensure that
south africa gains access
to vaccines and is effective in the
deployment of vaccines in the public
government inefficiencies may mean mass
rollout will only be reached
in 12 months time
for more let's bring in ruth faden she's
the founder of the berman institute of
bioethics at johns hopkins university
and a member of the world
health organization's cove at 19
vaccines working group
welcome to dw where do you see the
biggest challenges
for a fair distribution of these
vaccines
the challenges are enormous at the
global level
and also within countries the
global challenges have to do with the
fact that
for reasons we can
easily understand if not completely
defend wealthy countries of the world
have made their primary commitment
securing vaccine for their own
populations
this has resulted in a significant lock
on supply for some vaccines for the
foreseeable future countervailing
that challenge
is the existence of something called the
kovacs facility
which is a global commitment to provide
vaccine
to all peoples of the world what
kovacs needs is more financial support
from wealthy countries more money coming
in to kovacs and also we need more
wealthy countries who are not currently
part of the kovacs
collaboration to be at least thinking
about
bilateral commitments to low and middle
income countries
also we need support for the world bank
on that note
g20 nations recently said they will
quote spare no effort
in ensuring equitable access to proven
vaccines how much is that commitment
worth
well let's put it this way it's worth a
whole lot more than the countries who
are
high income who have not yet made that
kind of a pledge and i
include in that the united states my own
country so while of course we never
know until we really see what happens
what a pledge like that from a group of
wealthy countries is actually worth i
have to applaud uh this collection of
countries the european countries
for even making that commitment now we
see the biontech pfizer vaccine being
rolled out in
several countries the latest being the
united states we nee we know it needs to
be stored at
extremely low temperatures now doesn't a
prerequisite like that
in itself hamper a fair and equitable
distribution
absolutely so this is a banner day in
the united states the very first
uh people will be receiving the pfizer
pfizer biontech vaccine today in the u.s
but it is not a vaccine that is part of
the
solution to global equity at least not
in its current formulation
so if you were to grade that vaccine
right now
in terms of the likelihood that it will
contribute to global equity it would get
a poor mark
reformulations perhaps otherwise but
right now we have to look to other
vaccine types
to address the needs of people living in
low and middle income countries
essential workers and senior citizens
are among the first to be vaccinated
from an ethical point of view is that
the right thing to do
it's an important framing and it is
as defensible as other strategies that
we can think of
the problem comes with the competing
interpretations of equity that
are at issue so if you think about
countries
like the us or britain or south africa
or
pretty much many countries in the world
there are
profound background inequities
pre-existing
in the population with respect to health
and well-being more broadly
and those inequities are reflecting
themselves in disproportionate
burden of the pandemic now so the
challenge from an equity point of view
is to have is to make sure that your
prioritization
strategy addresses these gaps
ruth faden of the berman institute of
bioethics at johns hopkins
university and a member of the world
health organization's cove at 19
vaccines working group
thank you for your thoughts my pleasure
and now it is over to our resident
coronavirus expert
dw science correspondent derek williams
answering your questions
about the pandemic
if a vaccine is not a hundred percent
effective
can you still catch the virus after
vaccination
first of all no vaccine that we've
developed for any disease has ever
provided
perfect protection to everyone although
although a few
like those for measles or for polio
come very close but because every
person's immune system is different
in some people exposed to sars cove 2
the new vaccines
will not stop the coronavirus in its
tracks
trials and healthy volunteers indicate
however that the candidates now being
authorized for use in countries around
the world
are highly effective at doing so in most
people
it's kind of complicated but a
simplified
way of quantifying the efficacy
demonstrated in trials would be to say
that if you haven't been vaccinated
you're around
nine times more likely to contract
symptoms of covet 19
after an exposure than you would be if
you'd gotten the shot
so it drastically reduces that
possibility
but what's really interesting is that
for a return to something like
normal vaccines don't actually have to
prevent
covid19 in everyone if they can just
stop the disease
in many or most people then that's half
the battle
especially if they also limited spread
so if they keep
most vaccinated people from transmitting
the virus to others
for every person that can't catch the
virus and then
subsequently give it to someone else
we're one step closer to herd immunity
um as the virus finds fewer and fewer
unprotected hosts that'll slow the speed
of the pandemic
and and eventually stop it and there's
another possible upside
which is that even if getting a vaccine
isn't
an iron-clad guarantee that you won't
get
covet-19 later there are at least some
indicators that if you do
the vaccine could limit its severity so
you might then very well have milder
[Music]
symptoms
you